buon pomeriggio a tutti
a mio parere c'è sempre l'idea che le
crisi a soffrono di pessima reputazione
o contrario credono a mia modesta
opinione dovrebbe essere il contrario
dovrebbero essere celebrate in un certo
senso anche
considerate qualcosa di molto positivo
nella frase lei in effetti racchiude
questa idea della della crisi cioè
dell'idea di che le crisi né molto
spesso portano cambiamenti quindi c'è la
leather aria non seguire più cose che
magari si legano passato magari ne sono
state fatte perfetta per tantissimo
tempo e quindi c'è un cambiamento socio
culturale o politico e così via
ovviamente un esempio
molto
chiaro relazione all'idea della della
crisi è quella della della famiglia e se
in questo momento si chiedesse a un
bambino o magari un bambino che sa che
vive nel mondo del west world
di disegnare che non la fa con la
propria famiglia
ovviamente il disegno avrà un papa una
mamma magari un fratello o una sorella e
se ci sono anche dei cani e dei gatti a
casa vivono con con loro ma se si
chiedesse a questi bambini tra un paio
di anni di disegnare la propria famiglia
sarebbe completamente diverso
questi due bambini sono dei tuoi bling
bling un nuovo termine della del
dizionario in effetti contemporaneo che
è formato dalla parola twins e siblings
quindi da gemelli e anche da fratelli o
sorelle e nasce relazione alle nuove
tecnologie che vengono utilizzate per la
fecondazione artificiale oppure
l'utilizzo di surrogates di persone che
portano gravidanze avanti per altre
persone e loro sono dei tuoi bling
perché questa coppia a lei seduta e lui
sul lato destro hanno deciso di avere un
bambino però purtroppo le non poteva
portare avanti la gravidanza quindi
hanno scelto una donna a pagandola per
portare avanti la gravidanza della
utilizzando popolo della
proprio volo che veniva da lei quasi
sono detti facciamo un bambino perché
non ne facciamo due allo stesso tempo
quindi hanno pagato un altra donna ed
hanno contemporaneamente ha avuto due
bambini allo stesso momento però da due
donne diverse e quindi da quello il
termine i tuoi bling quindi la cosa
diventa un po complicata quindi
chiedendo a loro di disegnare la
famiglia il disegno che abbiamo visto
precedentemente sarebbe un po
completamente diverso perché inizia ad
avere delle persone che partecipano in
che sono socialmente magari non legate a
loro però biologico biologicamente o
magari hanno delle relazioni che sono un
po diverse da come intendiamo nella
dinamica in cui viviamo in questo
momento e con cui la famiglia viene
considerata in questo momento la stessa
cosa se viene che se si chiedesse alla
bambina nella fotografia di chiede di
disegnare la propria famiglia in romania
lei la donna sul lato destro viene
considerata forse una delle donne più
anziane qui ha dato vita a una riuscita
ad avere una gravidanza molto tardi in
se ricordo bene sono 67 68 anni
ovviamente se si chiede a lei di
disegnare la propria famiglia sempre
nuovamente sarebbe completamente diversa
e della stessa cosa di john mcclain a
una persona molto ricca in inghilterra
voleva avere dei figli ma non volevo
avere una relazione con una donna perché
aveva paura che magari se ci fossero
stati dei problemi di litigio e così via
ci sarebbe stato il problema dei bambini
che dove andare a chi darli quindi ha
deciso di andare su internet
e
utilizzando un sito come magari se lo si
fa per acquistare altre cose ha comprato
un ovulo ha scelto una donna ed è lui in
inghilterra queste persone era un
america dopo nove mesi sono nati dei tre
bambini triplettes la cosa interessante
di questa cosa qui è che a questa cosa
il modo in cui vengono scelte queste
cose vengono fatte in modo come diceva
quasi come per esempio acquistare
un'autovettura si scelgono il colore
dell'interno il colore dell'esterno la
cilindrata e così via
se si va su uno di questi stati
inizialmente si sceglie la tipologia per
esempio siccome questa in america si può
scegliere lo stato da cui la persona
proviene la razza oppure la re il tipo
di religione una volta che da fatta la
prima scelta ci sono varie persone che
short list se vogliamo del dei profili
che se stati iniziati che sono stati
scelti all'inizio e poi cena se si
clicca su una di queste persone c'è un
profilo molto più completo con delle
cose magari registrate per la voce
oppure per legate all'educazione al tipo
di aspirazioni che hanno e così via qui
per esempio c'è il prezzo del donatore
ovviamente se la persona già ha donato
degli ovuli e sono stati hanno
contribuito alla nascita di un bambino
di una bambina costa molto di più
ovviamente è una questione di mercato
e poi ci sono
delle cose un po ancora più interessanti
questa è un'azienda in america che si
chiama california cryobank ed hanno un
programma che si chiama a donal logue
likes hanno una data bank di donatori di
sperma che assomigliano a persone famose
quindi è possibile scegliere in questa
lista per esempio dello sperma di una
persona che assomiglia bill gates oppure
a danny de vito ed è una cosa abbastanza
interessante dal profilo socio culturale
uno si chiede per quale motivo deve
scegliere però fondamentalmente ci dà la
possibilità di scegliere le cose che in
un certo senso sì ad alcune persone fa
anche piacere ed è quella è una cosa
interessante dal profilo di l'idea di
pensare cioè di distinguere le due cose
del consumatore del cittadino come
cittadini noi in effetti siamo molto
facciamo delle critiche ci interessiamo
a cose magari ci arrabbiamo e così via
partecipiamo a dibattiti però come
consumatori e molto spesso siamo
irrazionali quindi le cose che facciamo
con pensionati sono molto diverse dalle
cose che facciamo come cittadini e
queste cose qua sono interessanti nel
nel contesto se pensiamo della crisi
perché ovviamente poi bisogna pensare
alle due cose in modo parallelo come
design è una delle cose che ho cercato
di fare nei mesi scorsi e nei
nell'ultimo decennio è quello di
avvicinarmi a temi come in questo caso
della famiglia il cambiamento della
famiglia peak auto in crisi perché mi
piacerebbe pensare all'idea della
famiglia che cambia più che altro
famiglia in crisi una delle menti come
bisogna uno sviluppato delle idee in
relazione a queste a queste varie aree
di ricerca una delle varie cose che ho
pensate in con nel contesto della idea
della surrogates cioè della dell'idea
che c'è una donna magari in un altro
paese che porta la gravidanza avanti per
una fan per una coppia una persona che
ha pagato con la persona una delle cose
che non puoi fare da distanza e
controllare se la persona per esempio
fumi o magari a mangia delle cose che
non fanno bene oppure beve ci sono delle
cose che magari fa che quante potrebbero
danneggiare la salute del bambino
questo è un servizio che dà la
possibilità di della persona che al
rapporto avanti la gravidanza di mettere
un cerotto digitale che registrate
alcune delle fisse a fisiologia della
persona quindi a distanza atlete è
possibile controllare se la persona ben
utilizzare il call oppure fuma o magari
fa delle cose che mai potrebbero
danneggiare la
salute del bambino un'altra idea è
quella di ovviamente c'è il rapporto
quando la gravidanza e nello stesso
nella stessa casa c'è un rapporto molto
diretto tra i genitori se vogliamo le
persone che sono lì quindi c'è il
contatto anche quotidiano con la mco la
con la mamma in effetti che che in
gravidanza
cioè ci sono moltissime persone che
parlano in effetti alla pancia se
vogliamo al bambino che all'interno
della
della donna e anche addirittura suonano
della musica che magari potrebbe piacere
a loro ovviamente se sei a distanza
questa cosa non può non puoi farla in
questo caso utilizzando questo oggetto e
mettendo questa parecchio sulla pancia
della donna da distanza la possibilità
di parlare alla pancia e di anche
suonare della musica magari preferita e
mandarla alla questa persona che magari
vi vengono in un altro paese
la terza idea sono dei giocattoli che
vengono utilizzati 1 con
una pancia se vogliamo l'altro è uno
sperma e un altro è un ovulo e relazione
a come vengono utilizzati si può
spiegare ai bambini come sono in effetti
sta come sono nati o come la famiglia è
stata costruita relazione come vengono
utilizzati tra di loro
e mi piacerebbe terminare con questa cus
di wells che un science fiction write
che in effetti dice che la crisi di oggi
e in effetti è la barzelletta di domani
grazie